[Music]
thank you so much for having me i'm
super excited to be here today to talk
about
delta lake and how it can make it easier
to manage your data lakes
however before i get into that i want to
kind of start by talking about the world
before delta
and i want to do that with uh kind of a
you know
the promise of the data lake why we
think data lakes are actually pretty
cool because there's some people who say
you know
why would you even use a data lake why
is it better than a traditional
relational database or data warehouse
and i actually think there are some
important things there that make them
significantly better
and a big part of it is this idea that
you should just collect
everything you have a lot of data it
could be structured customer data it
could be
stuff like video and speech it could be
stuff coming from iot sensors
um and the nice thing about the data
lake is it's cheap and it's super
scalable so you can actually collect
everything
you don't have to spend a bunch of time
up front putting a schema on it you
might say
why is that good well it takes time to
put a schema on it you don't know what
data is valuable ahead of time all the
time
and so with the data lake you just
collect everything and the idea is once
you've collected everything
you store it all in your data lake and
now you can do machine learning and data
science you can build recommendation
engines you can cure cancer with
genomics and dna sequencing
um but i have kind of a bad news for you
the dirty secret here is your data is
garbage
almost always when you first get it and
so you store garbage data in your data
lake and you have the standard problem
of garbage in
garbage out and so your analyses your
machine learning are also incorrect
and why is this like what what actually
does it look like when you build a data
lake project and what are some of the
challenges that you run into
well i'm going to start with kind of a
fairly simple setup uh you know i'm sure
many of you have done this in your in
your day jobs but
the problem is this my boss came to me
and he's got a stream of events in kafka
and he wants me to do two different
things with them he wants me to do
streaming analytics
we can understand what's happening uh
you know with our business in real time
and he also wants me to do ai and
reporting where i take a more
longitudinal historical view
and maybe predict what's going to happen
in the future by looking at what
happened in the past
so how do we go about doing this well
i'm obviously a little bit biased but i
would start by using spark
it has an awesome built-in connector to
speak to kafka
it has uh streaming apis that do cool
things like event time aggregation
uh and so you know we can kind of write
some spark sql queries and get that
streaming analytics
uh unfortunately that brings us to
challenge number one which is historical
queries
kafka is great when you want to know
what's happening at this moment when you
want to store a week or maybe a month of
data
but if you start throwing petabytes of
data in kafka things are probably going
to tip over
so i did a bunch of reading on the
internet and it seems like there's this
pattern
called the lambda architecture and as
far as i can tell this just means you do
everything
twice we're going to have a streaming
system that computes stuff in real time
we'll have a batch system that stores
data and computes it you know
asynchronously and batch fortunately
spark has
uh you know unified apis for streaming
in batch so it's relatively simple to do
this but
still two sets of programs and schedules
and errors that i need to deal with
but you know i'm a good engineer i can
get this done so we set up the lambda
architecture
we start storing data in the data lake
uh we'll add that to our kind of list of
solutions that we need to have
and now we can do ai and reporting
directly out of that data lake that we
created
done right that unfortunately brings us
to challenge number two which is messy
data
and the kind you know this is exactly
what i said before you know garbage in
so uh this is a you know again i've seen
this this problem solved quite a bit
uh a typical way to do it is you write a
whole bunch of validation programs or
you use one of these validation
frameworks like dq
or great expectations you write a bunch
of separate validations
um and you run them and they
you know email you when something goes
wrong and you go in and you fix your
program to handle that particular kind
of messy data
because of the lambda architecture i
have to introduce these validations into
two different places but you know again
unified apis make this
relatively simple and so we'll we'll go
ahead and set that up
and add validations to our list of
things and we're good to go
that unfortunately brings us to
challenge number three which is mistakes
and failures
so it was great that we added these
validations but they don't catch
problems until they've already made it
into the data lake
and so i actually need to go and correct
incorrect data that has made it into
storage
and this isn't a relational database
it's just a bunch of files that are
stored out there
so modifying them in place can be
difficult so a pretty common pattern
here
is to set up a reprocessing framework so
the idea is
instead of storing all of your data in
one giant directory we'll partition it
and usually time is a good dimension
here we'll partition it by days
hours minutes whatever kind of makes
sense for the scale of data i'm working
with
and we'll build this reprocessing
framework so that if anything goes wrong
now i don't have to reason about
updating data in place which is very
difficult and you know an
eventually consistent file system
instead we'll delete everything and
reprocess that partition of data and
we'll use that to correct these mistakes
and failures
that and that works so we'll add that to
our kind of bag of tricks
and that unfortunately brings us to
challenge number four
which is updates gdpr happens ccpa
happens these things where you're not
really just updating a single partition
you actually need to scan your entire
data lake
and you know respect somebody's right to
be forgotten
or you want to do change data capture
you have a feed coming from your
operational system and you want to
merge those updates into a table so this
is a whole other set of things we need
to do
um but you know we're good spark
engineers we can write spark programs to
do these it's just a bunch of
filters and joins and projections and
things so we write all of those jobs we
run them against the data lake we're
very careful to deal with partial
failures in fact
it's actually really hard um and we got
to be very careful because
while we're modifying it there's no
isolation so we'll schedule it we'll do
all of our work
at night and uh you know we'll tell
other people to run their reports during
the day
i've seen a whole bunch of solutions to
this i even saw one person
who because they were afraid of these
kind of uh you know scheduling and
atomicity problems
at once every 30 days they actually just
copied their entire data lake
and filtered out the people that wanted
to be forgotten so they were cutting it
just down to the wire of the gdpr
deadline but again we're good engineers
we can make this work but
as you can see there's a whole bunch of
challenges this system that was just
going to be me doing some data analytics
became this very complicated distributed
system and
really i think kind of the theme here is
you're wasting time and money
solving these well-known systems
problems instead of doing what your
actual job is which is to extract
value from data and just to kind of
summarize the distractions that i think
keep you from getting your job done
uh you know the data lake by itself has
no atomicity this means that when one of
your production job
fails in the middle it leaves partial
results out there so your table is
actually in a corrupt state and you need
to figure out how to fix it
partitioning is one strategy but that
doesn't work when you need to change you
know the entire table
and there's no quality enforcement
nobody stops me from dropping data in
that is incorrect or that doesn't match
the schema
and i don't find out until read time
that there was a problem here
and then finally there's no support for
consistency or isolation so it's up to
me to
have very careful schedules so two
people aren't modifying or reading the
same table at the same time
it makes it almost impossible to mix uh
streaming and batch into the same
workload
uh and all of these together mean that
you spend a lot of time distracted
and so i kind of want to switch over now
to talk about delta lake and how it
makes it significantly easier
so we're going to take this very
complicated architecture and we're going
to replace it
with this where data kind of moves
uh you know incrementally and you're
going to improve it and
the the tricks that make this possible
are first of all we have full acid
transactions
so this is a standard database concept
you know it's atomic consistent isolated
and durable
and this means that really each of those
programs acts as though it's operating
in complete isolation
and you never really have to worry about
the failures because if they happen it
cleans up
after itself and uh in addition to
having uh you know asset transactions
delta lake is an open standard and it's
fully open source
uh last year we announced that we were
donating the project to the linux
foundation
and i think this is really important you
know data has gravity it has inertia
if i was storing petabytes of my
organization's most valuable data
somewhere
i wouldn't want that to be some
vendor-specific black box format and so
you know we're working with the presto
community starburst announced their
their reader for it
we have a great connector for spark we
also have a connector for hive
and the entire transaction protocol is
out there on github if you want to
implement your own connector for
you know the processing framework or
machine learning framework of your
choice
and then finally uh you know the current
implementation is uh
deeply powered by spark and the nice
things about this are
unifies streaming and batch so any of
the spark sql apis works seamlessly with
with delta lake
and it's very easy to convert your
existing jobs you really only have to
change one or two lines of code and you
just get these much nicer semantics
and i'll actually show an example later
in this talk of what it's like to take
an existing spark program and convert
it so now i want to simplify the picture
a bit
and i want to talk about some patterns
that start to emerge
once you stop being distracted by these
distributed systems problems
and start focusing on data quality and
one of the things that i've seen a lot
and
i want to kind of clarify here these are
generalities these are not specific
features of delta
uh but these are what happen when you
start thinking about quality rather than
systems problems
so the first thing is you start
realizing that what you really want to
do is you want to incrementally improve
the quality of your data until it's
ready for consumption
it's not a one-stop process and i think
that's actually a good thing and i want
to walk through kind of each of the
steps and why each of them is valuable
so starting at the beginning we have our
bronze data or our raw data
and this is a dumping ground for
everything and as i said before i think
it's actually valuable that you can
collect this raw garbage data
because you don't know what's going to
be valuable later this might be the one
feature that you actually need to train
your model
and you know get better predictive
performance and one of the nice things
here is delta lake makes it possible to
store
years and years of data in a single
table and i'll show you kind of later
how we handle all of the scalability
here
another kind of magic trick about
storing the raw data
is you avoid error prone parsing there
are no bugs in a parser that you don't
write
and so that means that if there ever is
a mistake in your later analysis
you can always go back and reprocess the
original data
after bronze comes silver so this is
where i've started to do filtering or
augmentation
uh you know i've kind of cleaned up i've
normalized um
and you know this you might ask why are
we materializing this if it's not the
final answer isn't it expensive to store
it
and there's actually a couple of them
and one of them a couple of reasons and
one of them i found kind of surprising
so one is of course this intermediate
data might be useful for your co-workers
so uh you know having it there available
to them as a materialized table
is is a great way to kind of share that
work that you did already
the thing that surprised me more that i
found a bunch of people doing though
is actually using these intermediate
tables for debugging
when something is wrong with your gold
analysis it's very helpful to have the
full power of sql
to query these intermediate results you
can ask questions like in how many cases
was this column null
or how many distinct values were here
and that will help you find what's going
wrong in your etl process
and then finally we get to gold data
this is clean data ready for consumption
you can read it with spark or presto i
should have updated this slide because
presto support
is actually already available now uh and
so you know you can plug it into all of
your favorite tools or even bi tools um
which i think is actually pretty cool
and there's a couple of other patterns
that i've seen a lot of people get
success with
in the delta lake one is an increased
use of streaming so the idea here
is rather than a bunch of batch jobs
that move data through the data lake
uh you'll use streaming and the reason
here is streaming is
actually about incremental etl a lot of
people think that it's this very complex
thing that you do
only when you want really fast you know
low latency performance and that is
something we support
but the thing that streaming really is
is asking the question
what data has changed since the last
time i ran this job
how do i take that new data only process
it incrementally push it downstream
well checkpointing where i'm at in case
there's a failure so i can pick up where
i left off
that's a lot of manual code that people
have to write in their batch jobs that
is just
automatically taken care of for you when
you use streaming
and uh you know the kind of nice thing
here is you still do have this costly
cost latency trade-off that you can make
pretty easily
if you want low latency you can use a
micro batch or continuous processing
mode
if you want you know if your data only
arrives once a month and you don't want
that cluster running all the time you
can use trigger once mode
and uh and i think that really kind of
allows you to pick the right
cost for any particular application
of course it's not all streaming delta
has full support for batch jobs as well
including all of the standard dml that
you're familiar
with from your data warehouse so you can
do inserts update delete merge you can
atomically
overwrite multiple partitions and this
is great for problems like retention
when you're only allowed to keep data
for a certain period of time
corrections uh you know change data
capture and also as i mentioned before
gdpr
and another really powerful thing about
using streaming and about keeping all of
the raw data around is it makes it easy
to recompute when business logic changes
or when there's a bug
if at any point you want to do a
backfill and you want to kind of
reprocess all of your data from the
beginning of time
it's as easy as clearing out the table
or creating a new table
and creating a new checkpoint and what
happens when you start a stream off of a
delta table
is it starts by taking a snapshot of the
table at the moment the stream was
started
it takes that snapshot and breaks it up
into little pieces so it can process it
incrementally
and then as soon as it's done processing
the state of the world at that moment it
starts tailing the transaction log
looking for new data that has arrived
continually keeping the results up to
date
and so what you get is this really
efficient incremental spark job it's
actually much easier to scale and run
than a traditional spark job
even when you're processing petabytes of
data
so i want to talk a little bit about
people are using it now the project has
been out for almost three years now
it's used by thousands of organizations
around the world and we process
exabytes of data per month i want to
talk about one particular use case which
is comcast
uh you know in this case you know i'm
sure we're all familiar with with
comcast but this particular problem
uh they wanted to do sessionization they
had people
uh you know clicking going back and
forth from espn to the home shopping
network back to espn and they want to
really understand that content journey
so you want to take all of those clicks
group them by user and segment them by
time
uh and they were running this on spark
for years but
in the past it turns out it was just too
big for spark to handle
and what they ended up doing is what any
good engineer would do when they have a
scalability problem
they take it and they partition it by
user id so they're just going to hash
partition the users across a bunch of
different clusters
in this case they had 10 different
clusters with 10 different spark jobs
and they were able to get it to run
however
uh you know that's now 10 extra
schedules 10 extra clusters 10 sets of
errors to deal with
and so the kind of really cool thing is
when they switched to delta lake
uh because of our improved metadata
handling uh we were actually able to
collapse this down into one job
that actually used one tenth of the
hardware that they were using before
so it was both uh you know more
productive and faster in that regard but
it was also faster when it came to
uh you know the cost of running this job
and so i thought that was a pretty cool
result here
so if you're convinced you might be
asking how should i use this thing
and the answer is if you're an existing
user of spark it's super easy
all you need to do is add our library
you can
install it with just adding an argument
to the spark shell uh if you're building
uh you know a java or a scala program
you can depend on it with maven
uh and then and we're actually on pip
now if you want to install it there as
well
um but all you need to do is change the
format that you're reading from from
parquet
csv json whatever you're using today to
delta
and you will automatically get all of
the nice asset transactions and scalable
metadata management that we talked about
before
so now you might be saying this seems
too good to be true how can you possibly
get acid transactions on top of these
cloud storage systems i know they're
scalable but they
have eventual consistency so i'm going
to spend uh you know the last
couple of minutes walking through this
part
so first of all delta on disk is still
stored you know in the file system
along with a bunch of parquet files and
so you'll see there's kind of two
different sets of files here
we have the transaction log which has a
bunch of different json files and also
talk about the checkpoints in a moment
each of those represents a version of
the table as it moves through time
and then we also have these optional
partition directories
i say these are optional because
actually all of the partitioning is
handled by our transaction
log so you can also do exotic things
like
spread all of your parquet files out by
random partitions
if you're trying to optimize the
performance on s3 but
just for the sake of compatibility with
other systems and understandability
you know when compared to existing tools
by default we will still create those
partition directories
and then inside of them we have data
files and these are just standard
parquet that can be read read with any
system that supports parquet
but the trick here is rather than having
just one version of the table
we're actually going to have all of the
parquet files for multiple versions of
the table this is a kind of standard
database trick called
multiversion concurrency control or mvcc
and what we're going to do is we're
going to then have the transaction log
record how the table changes over time
so for any version you can figure out
what the current set of files are so in
each of those json files i showed before
there can be different actions and those
actions are basically the table
in the previous version plus those
actions create the new version
so an example of an action is you can
change the metadata of the table for
example i'll change its name or its
human readable description
i'll change the schema i'll change the
partitioning you record that by saying
here is the new metadata for the table
another operation is to add or remove
data from the table so we can add a file
or remove a file
and when we add a file we can also store
some optional statistics things like the
the min and max value
um of any given column the number of
nulls the number of rows
uh and and that is used later by the
system to do data skipping
and partition pruning uh and then
finally of course you know we
this isn't an append only structure so
we need to be able to remove data as
well so you can say remove this file
that was present in a previous version
from the table and so the result is when
you play the log forward to any specific
version
you can get uh you you get the current
state of the table which is here is the
metadata and here's the list of files
that are that are present
uh the other nice kind of trick here is
because you have all of these versions
stored you can also use this to do time
travel so you can actually go back in
time
by not playing the log all the way to
the end as long as you haven't deleted
those files
that's totally possible
[Music]
now so that's part of it that's that's
kind of how we get versioning and
consistency but now you're going to say
well how do we get atomicity that nice
trick that if
something happens it either happens
completely or it doesn't happen at all
and the trick here is when we create
those version files
we're going to do them using uh atomic
primitives on the
underlying file system so as an example
here let's say i want to do compaction i
have a bunch of data
and it's in small files i want to make
it into big files so
uh you know version zero adds these two
files to it
and then version one atomically removes
those two files and adds that data back
in
because we never want to be in the state
where the removes happen and not the ad
because then we lose data or the add
happens but not the removes because then
we would have duplicate data
and so when we create this json file
depending on the underlying file system
we'll use
different techniques for doing it on s3
uh
uploads are guaranteed to be atomic
because you start the put operation by
saying
here's how many bytes to expect don't
accept this right unless you get all of
these bytes
on other storage systems like gcs or
azure data lake
we'll use atomic rename so we'll create
a temporary file
and rename it to its final destination
and they guarantee we'll get
either none of the file or the entire
file when you do that operation
so we've got atomicity now but let's
talk about consistency
and in order to get consistency we're
going to try to ensure this property
called serializability which means that
there is
one serial schedule that explains how
the table has changed
even if multiple users were changing it
at the same time it'll be as
though they were going one at a time and
so in order for this to happen we have
to agree
on that order of changes even when there
are multiple writers to the table
so we're going to here rely on a a trick
called mutual exclusion
so the idea here is you know uh ver user
one creates version zero
user two creates version one but if they
both try to create version two at the
same time
one of them must be excluded they must
get an error that says nope
version two already exists you need to
check yourself and uh
and and see what happened and you might
say well wait a second if every time two
people do something at the same time it
fails
it sounds like i have a bunch of
conflicts to deal with
fortunately we have this kind of
conflict resolution policy
where we check to see if the set of
operations were done by these two users
are disjoint if they didn't overlap at
all we can say it doesn't matter what
order they went in
and so we can actually just kind of
resequence it and have user two
retry automatically uh you know creating
that next commit without these or even
knowing that there was a conflict
and so the trick for doing this is when
we when we uh
when we see that there's a conflict
basically we start by recording the
start version we record
any operations that happen we attempt to
commit and if somebody else wins
uh you know that user two just
automatically tries again
[Music]
uh the kind of final trick i want to
talk about here is massive metadata so
it's actually not uncommon for delta
tables to have hundreds of thousands
or even millions of files and anybody
who's tried to store
hundreds or even thousands of partitions
in the hype metastore knows
big metadata can really slow down and
hurt the stability
of your of your big data processing and
so
the trick here is we're actually going
to take metadata and we're going to try
to treat it
as data and use a data a big data
processing system to handle it
so how do we do that we just take all of
these actions that exist in the
transaction log
we read them in with spark we use a
spark shuffle
to kind of group by the file name cancel
out ads and removes
to come up with the current snapshot of
the table
and then we store that in parquet so in
most cases we're not actually reading
this super long transaction log and
needing to do all of this resolution
instead we just read this uh parquet
file find the files that are relevant
we can look at all of the statistics for
the files which are stored in there in
the checkpoint as well
identify only the files that are
actually relevant to our particular
query
uh and then uh you know pass that on to
spark where the real processing begins
and so with this trick now it doesn't
matter how big the table is
uh you can kind of you can still handle
handle it uh by leveraging spark kind of
out of core processing and shuffle and
all of those things
cool so with that i want to encourage
you to check out our website
uh you know delta dot io it has getting
started guide so you can try it out
we also link to the source code and the
protocol if you want to learn more
join us on slack we're super active
there so if you have questions about how
to use spark or delt or any of these
things
check it out
you